Have you ever found a knitting
pattern that you love,
but the neckline was too
high or way too low?
Recalculating a round neckline is the next
topic in our Pencil
and Paper Charting series.
If you missed the first three basics
tutorials, you'll want to watch them
first, we will build
on the skills learned.
Let's use this front neckline schematic
and make it a little more comfortable.
The pattern gauge is 7stitches
and 10.5 rows per inch.
The armhole is 9 inches deep
and the neckline in the original
pattern is 4 inches deep.
First thing we want to reset our row
counter to 000 at the beginning
of the armhole shaping.
Now we've decided we want our new
neck depth to be 6 inches deep.
That means we'll knit 3 inches
before we start our shaping.
If we do the math, we'll multiply
three times our row gauge,
do a little rounding and we'll see that
on row 32, we start our neckline shaping.
There will be a total of 64 rows
in the neckline to complete the piece.
Now the fun starts.
Let's figure out how to create
the curves for our round neck.
Let's start with our graph paper method.
We'll work with half of the neckline.
Mark off 28 stitches by 64 rows.
Remember to use knitting graph paper.
Now sketch a nice curve.
Quickly draw in some stitches
to follow the curve.
Now you'll notice that we're decreasing
three stitches every other row and then
two stitches every other rows,
and then three stitches every fourth row.
This is pretty messy,
difficult to knit, and hard to duplicate
on the other side of the neckline.
There's a better way.
Here's the classic formula
for shaping a neckline.
Bind off half the stitches.
Decrease the remaining stitches,
one stitch every other row, then knit
straight until the neckline is completed.
This gives you a pretty nice curve.
Remember, this is knitting,
and by the time you attach a band,
you'll never see that this
is a straight line decrease.
Finish by writing your pattern. At row 32,
bind off the center 28 stitches,
working each side separately.
Decrease on the neckline edge,
one stitch every other row 14 times
knit even to row 96.
Even though we did our calculations over
half the neckline,
it's common practice to bind off all
of the center stitches at one time.
This creates a nicer center front and
makes it easier to finish the neckline.
If this method isn't accurate enough
for your taste, there are other formulas
you can use to get a more
gradual and graceful curve.
I recommend the book
Knitwear Design Workshop as
an excellent resource for designing.
Purchasing from this
link supports Knit it Now.
Thank you for watching and look for many
more tutorials in the extensive
Knit It Now Learning Library.
Here's a link to all
the tutorials in this series.
Happy charting.